mon travail c'est de sauver
l'environnement pardon sauver
l'environnement
c'est ça mon travail
qu'est ce que vous faites de tous ces
déchets grâce je les vends et j'en tire
de l'argent et vous gagner beaucoup
d'argent avec ça oui oui combien
j'obtiens chaque mois en vendant le
plastique 300000 russia de profits soit
20000 dollars par mois pour faire
tourner sa petite entreprise où allait
lui aussi à embaucher des bengladais
tous portent un tee shirt au nom de sa
société comme sharif son travail glaner
des morceaux de métal
je ramasse tous les morceaux de métal
que je trouve je fais une cinquantaine
de cartons comme ça à chaque jour et
après ils sont revendus
sharifi arrivé il ya un mois sur l'île
poubelle comme les autres maldives
on lui avait promis un bon job mais
c'est ici qu'il a finalement atterri un
travail de chien comme tous les
travailleurs bangladais sharif est logé
sur l'île
j'ai vraiment faim là walid son patron
les a installés sur ce terrain vague lui
aussi jonchées d'ordures et c'est cet
ancien local réservé au matériel qui
leur sert de toit voyez là on vit à 7
il y a deux collègues qui dorment là
c'est vrai que c'est pas très
confortable et vous voyez on n'a rien
d'autre ici à 7 dans cette cabane faite
de parpaings et de tôles
il n'y a pas de place pour l'intimité
mais il n'y a pas non plus d'eau
courante walid leur a simplement
installé à l'extérieur un réservoir de
récupération d'eau de pluie offert par
une ong
c'est là que sharif fait un brin de
toilette on passe toutes nos journées
dans les ordures
il faut absolument se laver sinon on
tombe tout de suite malades pas
d'alternative à cette hygiène sommaire
bien insuffisante
quand on est quotidiennement au contact
de poussière et de fumée toxique et ce
n'est pas le seul problème de sharif et
ses collègues jetés ramener de l'eau
pour leur part ici on est tous plus ou
moins malade
moi j'ai des maux de vente par exemple
mais c'est ça le pire
le pire c'est que ça fait trois mois
qu'on n'est pas payant des conditions de
vie exécrables pas de rémunération leur
expérience maldivienne est en train de
virer au cauchemar pour nous les
bangladesh vivre ici c'est très
compliqué et j'imagine que pour les
touristes des maldives ça doit être le
paradis après leur pause où aller de
leur a discrètement distribué des
masques plutôt rudimentaire nous en
profitons alors pour l'interroger sur
les conditions de travail de ses
employés n'ont pour le moment seulement
ce gars se sentait mal
hier il est juste un peu malade parce
que je leur explique que ces fumées ne
sont pas très bonnes pour la santé
c'est pour ça que je leur donne des
masques mais parfois ils oublient de les
porter face à lui
aucun d'entre eux n'osera se plaindre ni
exiger son salaire
quand est-ce que vous avez payez vous
employez pour la dernière fois
pour le moment nous ne payons pas
pourquoi ils me posent cette question
celui-là avant-hier nous avons commencé
une collègue de la ferraille et
maintenant nous obtiendrons l'argent je
pense demain aujourd'hui
si nous recevons cet argent nous allons
payer ces gars donc ils ne sont pas
payés pour le moment il travaille pour
rien cet homme le jure
ces employés seront payés dans quelques
jours